hi i'm ginger gonzaga and i play nikki
ramos on she-hulk and i'm tatiana masani
and i play jennifer walters aka she-hulk
on she-hulk attorney law and my phone
just went uh dead we are going to take
the buzzfeed quiz which marvel character
are you a combination of
[Music]
pick a song to sing a karaoke with your
friends as it was by harry styles
driver's license by olivia rodrigo about
downtime by lizzo don't stop believing
by journey sweet caroline by neil
diamond
running up that hill by k-pop okay that
one absolutely running up that hill by
kate bush though i couldn't do it well
but i would try and she's wonderful i
think i would do driver's license by
olivia rodrigo because it's so funny me
to be like i'm in high school i just got
my license
i could do a whole act out
which superpower would you kind of hate
to have in real life mind reading time
travel shape-shifting x-ray vision
immortality super speed okay i can
already read mine so that's not an
option for me
i think x-ray vision i'm not trying to
just
see your guts all the time it's a little
perfect yeah yeah it's a little
consent
who's yours i would say the same i don't
need to see that stuff now which marvel
character would you want to team up with
him in the future remember this is
tatiana answering
okay captain america makari spidey
agatha harkness groot or captain marvel
i know what you're gonna pick i know i
am
i and i kind of feel like the same
because look how cute it is
it's groot it's groot forever i know i
really want to see makari because i
really want to learn how to
sign but baby groot like i can't betray
you
we've already got a good thing going
that's right
i can't wait for you to actually meet
bruce
baby baby choose a book to bring with
you while you travel the great gatsby
yeah we got stardust by neil gaiman okay
it ends with us by colleen hoover summer
i turned pretty by jenny han the seven
husbands by evelyn hugo of evelyn hugo
by taylor jenkins reed and pride and
prejudice by jane austen hmm
i'm not doing the great gatsby because
we all know zelda fitzgerald probably
had a hand to that and she didn't get
credit
correct i'm gonna go with even though i
know nothing about it the seven husbands
of evelyn hugo because you go girl
get yourself seven husbands what's going
on
i'm gonna go with stardust by neil
gaiman because he's pretty cool yeah
pick a trivia category that you would
absolutely win at so uh tv show theme
songs 80s bands famous authors 101
popular tick tock sounds general
knowledge or marvel cinematic universe
i'm definitely not going to go with
marvel's horrible cinematic viewers yeah
ginger and i probably know the least
about anything um i'll go with general
knowledge we're going to go with general
knowledge too sign me up for a couple
science questions or whatever yeah yeah
exactly math finally which mcu actor
would you love to star in a movie with
ooh this one tessa thompson we got
florence pugh we got sebastian stan
we've got zendaya we've got simulu
canadian we've got mark ruffalo
i'm gonna say florence pew
yeah
that's a good one i'm gonna go with
sebastian stan because we were on a show
together but i didn't get to work with
him yes and i wanted to yeah but they
killed him after the first episode so it
wasn't really yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry
for your loss thank you
oh okay
oh interesting i got who did you get
valkyrie and elena bellova so i'm my
personality matches valkyrie and elena i
am driven charming and clever like
valkyrie you're a natural-born leader
who isn't afraid to stand up for what
you believe in meanwhile just like elena
you're someone who leaps at the chance
to go on adventure your bravery is your
strongest asset yes we love a brave
okay i got
bucky barnes and wanda maxinoff uh
maximoff i'm very excited about this um
it says your personality matches bucky
and wanda you're loyal true passionate
and powerful all true like wanda you'll
do anything to protect the people
closest to you even if it means getting
yourself into some trouble i find this
to be true for myself this is
scientifically correct yes buzzfeed
understands psychology correct and all
of uh society and pop culture to the
point where it reads us perfectly i also
feel like you being on like various
sitcoms would be something i'd want oh
it'd be so funny yeah thank you thank
you buzzfeed for telling us what it is
thank you so much buzzfeed it was so
much fun and don't forget to watch
she-hulk attorney at law on disney plus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you